we will be back monday night or whatever
we don't [__] know yet until next
week
who gives a [__] have a great weekend
stay black
uh tomorrow's a tough day for our
country today's a tough day for our
country
it is what it is we're american [__]
as a matter of fact
the national anthem let's go we're going
to open up with the national anthem
player that's true
and no [__] [__] the harps and
people saying no i got it saved
yeah i want the good [__] not neil
diamond are you ready let's do this it's
september 11th people
[Music]
it's september 11th i know 10 12 years
ago we had disaster
and these [__] momos were walking
around what are we gonna do terrorist
the only [__] terrorist is the fear
you have of yourself
we're [__] americans you take that
plane that hit the world trade centers
and you stick that up somebody's [__]
[__] we're americans [__]
don't you ever [__] forget that that
means we do what the [__] we want to do
we're americans [__] isis [__]
terrorists [__] turbans [__] everybody
i hate all you [__] we're
[__] americans
that means nobody [__] stops us we
want our dicks up
we get our dicks up that's what an
american does
ask the [__] pilgrims [__] 9 11.
[__] 9 11 it'll never happen again
we're america you don't ever have to be
afraid again
[__] obama [__] them all
we're americans you son of a [__] grab
your guns
go shoot somebody
and you don't know dude
oh